[Musique]
d'après le bordel vous êtes en garde à
vue pour trafic de stupéfiants en
thérapie achevé sa bataille morale
un petit hôtel j'aime pas cette chambre
c'est pas un hôtel ici c'est un ehpad et
ça me coûte 3200 euros par mois à table
je prends ces d'abolition annales fabien
galthié lequel mathis machrek l'émirat
crade et au championnat l oppresseur de
l'autoroute puis je ne le porte pas bien
le cas ouattara
mika trouve aux camions khadija et a eu
combien dans ce camion balai pour moi
même temps n'est pas partir vu mes
billets de banque et drogues et demi non
celui là il est urgent de monsieur et
chercheurs
[Musique]
rouse arrivages blade devant un demi
mètre de frappe à 250 mois on bouge d'un
frère la galère ans elle est finie la
galère en salle est finie
anna madame ben barka et à batna ldc la
libyan
mabri à brittany mehiaoui meeting qui
m'a tout de suite si vous êtes des
crevards ya une femme qui guide des
tonnes de shit dans paris on est un cave
de la choper sur la tête de ma mère
c'est blanc opaque de chypre au top ça
fait toujours plaisir a comme clients
mécontents du produit c'est pourquoi ces
dictons travée est ce que ce chiffre là
que tu leur donnes il était vraiment
quelque chose de paradoxal chez toi tu
dégages étrangement sans toi ça
m'impressionnait dupré penser à des mecs
que j'ai deux coffrets et on dit qu'au
moins gros deux options en arabe ce bac
bien facebook
[Musique]